Kim Cattrall has plenty to say about
Sarah Jessica Parker never thought I'd
see this day you and me both in a
lengthy Instagram post on Saturday the
61 year old actress called out her
former Sex in the City co-star for
reaching out after her brother Chris
Cottrell died earlier this week writing
I don't need your love or support at
this tragic time your continuous
reaching out is a painful reminder of
how cruel you really were then and now
let me make this very clear you are not
my family you're not my friend
so I'm writing to tell you one last time
to stop exploiting our tragedy in order
to restore your nice girl persona
somebody in your life whether you're in
touch with them all the time or not and
they are suffering for any reason it's
it's it's it's involuntary that you want
to convey condolences or sadness or just
let someone know that you're thinking
about them we've never been friends
earlier this month
SJP revealed she was saddened by
previous comments made by Kim about
their friendship just heartbroken